Minutes
[Music]
Buberless
There is so-so
[Music]
No
Asakura march.
I'm the chief of the temple, who is the chief of the temple
.  It's the 7th generation. The
flower was turned up about 540 years ago,
but I've been thinking about it since then.
[Music]
When I was little, I didn't
like being told to pour a temple because you were a tracer
.  The reason is that temples are old-fashioned. Somehow
mysterious and
stiff. I was in my early twenties thinking smoothly. I wanted to
get out of Ota somehow,
so I did dj and lighting work.  There was a time when I wanted to go there, so as I continued that work, I said that there is no version
of lighting or net
dj to convey wonderful things.
I've noticed
that I think the child is very nice,
so I came back to the temple.
Well, the number
of people who visit the temple is gradually decreasing, so I have to do something in this situation.
So, it's
kind of like information, and
then
I sent it to the mirror without Mizumoto.
Based on that music, I used lighting and
projection mapping to decorate the inside of
the temple from gravure.
It is said that he is the king of music
. When I first started this memorial service, there were only people around me, but it
became 100 people
and 150 people in the form of an umbrella of rumors.  The people in front of you are
very wide. From the
angle to the elderly
, there are many people who come in 3 generations of parents and children. I
don't know how long the techno memorial service will last, but
you can do it.  I want to do as much as I can
[Music]